okay so listen if you've been watching
the David Pakman show if you listen to
this program you know that there are no
sacred cows here there's no idea or
person or anything that's above
criticism I'm a progressive but if I see
something on the left that I don't like
I criticize it earlier in the week I
criticized Alexandria Acacio Cortez some
people in the audience got mad others
appreciated that I call it like I see it
and that sometimes there's criticisms of
people on the left of course there are
Israel sometimes people get mad they
don't feel I'm criticizing Israel
harshly enough until I do and then
people get mad that I'm being unfair to
Israel all of a sudden left-wing
candidates who I interview if I don't
think that there is informed as they
should be I push them and I question
them and I don't handle them with kid
gloves my point is no sacred cows on
this program and in the past I've
criticized Jill Stein when I believed
that she deserved criticism few months
ago there was a report maybe it was
early June I guess almost two months ago
there was a report which said that some
of Jill Stein's millions of dollars
raised for recounts were widely
unaccounted for and mostly spent and
that she hadn't filed FEC disclosures
dating all the way back to I believe it
was September of 2017 I looked at the
report I did the underlying research and
I came to you with my views not
everybody agreed with me some of you
appreciated it and felt it was good some
people said that it was a hit piece
others said listen David you'd clearly
be slamming a Republican if the story
was about them Jill Stein shouldn't get
special treatment just because she's on
the left ultimately there was a
subsequent report to the report that led
to that story in early June and once
again it relates to Jill Stein's use of
those millions of dollars raised for the
recounts in certain states in the 2016
election and this latest report from The
Daily Beast goes into more detail about
the spending and it is now saying
specifically that some of that recount
money was used is being used to pay for
Jill Stein
legal troubles related to the Russia
investigation and as some of you know
and as some of you
don't know Jill Stein has been pulled in
to the Russia probe and is suspected of
possible wrong wrongdoing
she has dined with Putin and the
indicted Michael Flynn in Russia
documents have been requested from her
she's had dealings with the United
States Senate Select Committee on
Intelligence and she has not as of yet
been charged with anything but she has
had not insignificant legal expenses
related to this and for a while her
campaign hadn't released an FEC filing
outlining their spending
they now have and it's raising more
questions because the stein campaign
paid the partnership for civil justice
about sixty six thousand dollars in May
and another $31,000 in January and that
is a law firm that is representing Jill
Stein in her dealings to related to the
Russia probe now we don't know for sure
if the hundred thousand paid to them by
the Jill Stein from the Jill Stein
money's were for representing her in the
Russia probe or if they're also
representing her on something else but
we know that they're representing her on
the Russia probe and that payments were
made to them another example nine
thousand dollars went to Miller and
Chevalier which works with Paul Manafort
related to the Russia probe we don't
know if Jill Stein's $10,000 payment to
them was for Russia related stuff but
once again it would appear that way and
of course Jill Stein has every right to
have attorneys for the Russia stuff she
absolutely should everybody deserves to
be represented by attorneys if they are
being investigated but the Stein
campaign has said time and time again
that the money they raise for the
recounts would be held separately and
would be used only for recounts and yet
again it doesn't appear that that's
what's going on the FEC law around this
says that money raised for recounts can
be used for post-election litigation but
it has to be litigation related to the
recounts or the counting of ballots and
if indeed Jill Stein's
money is being used the recount money is
being used for russia-related legal fees
that would not be part of what the FEC
says is okay
Jill Stein's being investigated and what
The Daily Beast is alleging or
suggesting is that money raised under
the premise of being used for recounts
is being used to cover her personal
legal expenses as related to the Russia
probe my belief on the basis of all the
evidence and I know that people will
write in and say that I'm wrong although
they'll say that I have a personal
vendetta against Jill Stein I will lose
subscribers but I'm not going to sort of
be held hostage for membership errs or
subscribers if I believe that something
is one-way and not not the other way to
me the entire Jill Stein recount thing
stinks it feels to me as though it is a
calculated and conniving thing that was
done and that it is a combination of
grifting and cash-grab
ISM and if you think I'm wrong provide
evidence that I'm wrong but once again
we have another report which alleges
that money raised to be used for
recounts is being used for other things
and that is direct disrespect to the
people who donated the money and if you
don't like what I'm saying write in and
I know some of you will and tell me how
the report is also unfounded as some
people said the last one was and I will
do a follow-up I have no problem
whatsoever this episode is sponsored in
part by better help calm slash Pakman
which gives you access to a fully
licensed and experienced psychologists
or therapists through videophone and
text I know from the emails I get that
in our audience like in the broader
world there are people who are
struggling with different issues in
their lives and many of them choose not
to talk to somebody about it
either for financial reasons for reasons
of stigma associated with seeking out a
therapist and I think it's really
important to do everything you can to
get past that because it's really
important to talk to someone when you
feel like that's the right thing to do
and what better help calm provides is
number one
the elimination of the stigma that could
be associated with it you work through
video phone whichever method is best for
you
you also will be able to save money
compared to seeing an in-person
therapist and it is so easy to get
started that I encourage you to go to
better help calm slash Pakman a few
questions that you answer which will get
you paired up with a therapist that
meets your needs you can always switch
to somebody else if you don't feel as
though the match is a good fit and it is
something that everybody should have
access to go to better help calm slash
Pakman it's easy to sign up it's easy to
get started we've put a link in the
description if you're watching on
YouTube and once again that website is
better help calm /pa K M a.m.